Andy did you go to film school yeah I
went to USC for their grad program and
production which is you know kind of
covers writing directing producing and
so you did the basic you know film
school experience there so what did film
school teach you and then what did you
wish that I had taught you
I mean the biggest part of it is just
suddenly being thrown into a group where
you're you know you have to make movies
you you know you have these deadlines
set for you and you have to produce
itself and and you instantly have a
circle of other filmmakers that you're
doing that could take you know if you're
out in another city or wherever it could
take a long time to find these people
willing to put in the same effort as you
are into these into making you know
short movies and writing and that's
still probably the biggest aspect for me
of was just you know looking for that
extra turn to be just jumped and thrown
into production and then and then you
know you find some mentors who are going
to push you towards the kind of
filmmaking you want to make or the
things you're writing and so in a yeah
you've you've you know USC there there's
you know plentiful there and I think
that the big things I look at taking you
know working with actors is it would
have you know the kind of education that
you get with people there would be I
think it would be more difficult to get
outside you know it was
yeah I mean I I suppose yeah there's
always like classes you can take and
other things but I can't imagine you
know that you get the same level you
know when you're with the people that
you're working with there what did what
did film school maybe not teach you by
omission or whatever just that was
extremely important that you had to
learn maybe the hard way or maybe not so
hard through through word of mouth but
what was something that really might be
better suited to be implemented into
some curriculum what would be the best
thing is it access to funding I don't
know I've never been to film school so I
don't know the exact great I mean I
don't know if anybody can teach you you
know access to funding or you know how
you figure out those those channels or
you know there certainly some classes in
that and you know I don't think I
gravitated as much to that side of of
the program but I'm either the bigger
thing is you know it might not be
something it might not be something
they're explicitly don't teach it just
as that it's not in the purview of
responsible education is you know price
probably the risks that you're going to
take going out and making small movies
both from you know whether its financial
or you know the lying cheating stealing
aspect of it you know that that nobody
would encourage you to do that that is
you know part of it whether it's just
convincing people to let you shoot in
someplace that you're not supposed to be
or having a not or you know having the
wherewithal to say yeah I'm going to
shoot here because you know there might
be some consequences but we'll try to do
it I think the you know that gets lost a
little bit in terms of you know the
level of production and I think even
beyond that you know and I might have
been on the cusp of the change you know
I don't know what
it's like now but things were still
geared a little bit more towards kind of
higher priced you know what does a
larger production look like even for
short films you know a large crew and in
all these things versus you know making
smaller movies and and you know there
might be a little rough around the edges
but getting you know larger pieces done
and getting them out there and I think
you know that aspect was was missing a
bit from from a film school environment
you